people taking your mail that's not okay
that's something we got to confront as a
society I cry every time I watch Harry
Potter so we'll see if this does it for
me a lot of chiseled white people
falling in love gals Lee's got balls
she's into it whoa this dude's creepy
see that is psychotic if someone did
that in real life I would just assume
that they're like body parts in his
freezer
this guy's always pulling stunts isn't
he what'd you do on your date tonight
sweetheart not laid in the road be
careful you'll cut yourself on his
chiseled jawline now people say stuff
like call me daddy they used to say
stuff like say I'm a bird
look at that mustache uh okay long ago
yeah you don't ask somebody how much
money they make she's gonna show her is
Gosling he's here that what you say I
love you
yo love each other love Tim are you Oh
class for class for class war you barged
in
damn you in your perfect jawline and
your dreamy eyes oh don't kiss him why
it's just so salon-quality hair after me
paint naked god
she's gonna take her down to the lumber
mill and short how the other half lives
at any point in time she could have been
like here you go and she didn't every
single day for a year
I'm just saying a handwritten letter
isn't creepy because I've done it and
I'm hoping it's not creepy stop thinking
about what I'm or what he wants
parents want what do you want she want
she watch what God this was like
amazingly depressing I can see why
everyone 2004 was really hyped up on the
notebook pick a lumberyard boy was so
sad the quality sperm comes from
lumberyard boys's I guess what I'm
trying to say
love isn't actually like this but we
want it to that's not true you watch
this movie and you think that's special
someone and trying to be half as good as
half those guys you know a little bit of
a Ryan Gosling fan will do pidrive fan
decided to watch the notebook wondering
if he shoots anybody in this it looks
like he's gonna shoot some people